Trascrizione: Alessia Campedel
Revisore: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Vorrei fare un viaggio con voi,
un viaggio verso un futuro che non c’era.
Sì , un mondo del lavoro nuovo.
Cosa troveremo in questo mondo?
Beh, le persone non saranno, evolveranno.
Qui ci sarà un altro elemento
che mi piace mettere
in questo nuovo futuro del lavoro.
Le idee non avranno gerarchia.
E l’ultima ciliegina sarà...
che risultato, motivazione e benessere
saranno in equilibrio
sia per le persone che per la comunità.
Certo, viaggeremo tra il cinismo.
Il mondo è così, purtroppo.
Ma ce lo dicono perché non
vogliono cambiare.
Proviamo a percorrerlo questo viaggio.
Partiamo dalle persone.
Le persone, tutte, hanno un talento.
Questo talento emerge se si ha il tempo
di guardare qual è la propria vocazione.
Certo, ci raccontano attenzione,
coperti, allineati,
le paure che prevalgono,
le paure di bruciarsi.
Ma se andiamo sul terreno che amiamo,
il coraggio batte la paura.
Non esistono eroi.
Siamo tutti umani.
E quando la nostra vocazione è centrata.
La paura sparisce.
Certo, ci vuole quindi un vuoto al centro,
perché se le persone hanno standard,
se ci attendiamo da loro
la miglior versione di loro
che noi vogliamo,
prevale la paura.
Se cerchiamo di dire “c’è un
vuoto al centro, espanditi”,
io ti sopravvaluto.
Come l’arciere quando mira un bersaglio
non lo mira puntualmente
perché altrimenti i fattori atmosferici
non farebbero arrivare la freccia.
Dobbiamo sopravvalutare le persone.
Le persone, in questo vuoto al centro
in cui le sopravvalutiamo, si espandono.
Ci sarà da gestire l'errore.
Una cultura dell'accettazione.
Certo, le persone dovranno avere
il coraggio di chiarire
qual è la propria vocazione.
Le idee non hanno gerarchia,
cosa vuol dire?
Vuol dire che l'organizzazione
le trova ovunque.
Un’azienda, una comunità, una realtà
che segue la gerarchia
si perde fiori e fiori di stimoli.
Se le idee non hanno gerarchia,
bisogna avere la capacità
di non competere con gli altri,
ma regalarle queste idee.
Quindi si compete con sé stessi.
Molte volte, per paura
che un’idea mia diventi tua, non la do.
E lì la comunità non fiorisce.
Certo, il talento di queste persone,
appunto, uso la metafora fiorire,
è un po’ come un fiore,
non si può fiorire ovunque.
Una stella alpina
portata in spiaggia, secca,
un papavero portato in montagna, ghiaccia.
E quindi il compito,
in questo vuoto al centro,
è di lasciare il talento esprimersi,
ma aiutarlo ad andare
nell’ambiente giusto per fiorire.
Ed è determinante.
Le persone sono arance,
non sono spicchi di arance.
E sovente le vediamo
solo per il loro spicchio, dovuto.
Che bello ampliare il discorso
di “Cosa ami?”
“Di cosa hai paura?”
“Cosa vuoi?”
In questo nuovo mondo del lavoro,
varrà esprimersi in maniera completa.
Non ci si potrà nascondere
dietro un mestiere.
D'altronde processi, sistemi si copiano.
Nel mondo del lavoro del futuro
in cui questi talenti fioriranno,
gli occhi delle persone, l’energia,
far scendere dalla testa al cuore
le decisioni
creerà barriere competitive inarrivabili.
Sarà l'umano il fattore di competizione.
E non si potrà copiare.
Ed ecco che anche i cinici
che si chiedono perché coltivare
questo tipo di espansione umana,
capiranno che le loro aziende
saranno invincibili solo con le persone.
Le aziende non hanno successo.
Hanno successo le persone
di quella azienda.
Ma andiamo avanti.
Sul risultato, sul fare, centinaia di anni
ci hanno spiegato come agire.
Ma sul sentire, sentire le paure,
sentire le emozioni, sentire la vocazione,
sentire la vulnerabilità,
siamo analfabeti.
Nessuno vuole toccare il binario del fare.
Io chiedo di valutare come
un binario del sentire possa potenziare
e rendere sostenibile nel tempo
quel risultato.
Veniamo al benessere.
Il benessere è fatto di due componenti:
stare bene, lì abbiamo psicologi e medici
che sanno fare
e funzionare bene.
Ecco che sul funzionare bene
si apre un tema.
Io funziono bene se faccio ciò che amo,
se lo so fare e se lo faccio
in una rete relazionale
che mi garantisca una meritocrazia
e una remunerazione delle mie attività.
E qua c'è tutto quello che possiamo fare.
Creare questa attenzione.
Io sono un marino.
Amo la montagna, non so sciare, però.
Se mi trovo su una pista impegnativa
il mio amore per la montagna
non mi fa stare bene, non so sciare.
Possono insegnarmelo, ma se scio da solo,
non essendo un monaco tibetano
ed essendo un networker
di nuovo non sto bene,
ho bisogno di sciare
con gli altri, ecco.
So fare le cose che amo
e lo faccio con gli altri.
Sarà la dimensione
di questo mondo del lavoro.
Andiamo alla motivazione.
Troppe volte ci hanno detto “Fai questo”,
“Formati su questo”, “Segui questo”
perché la motivazione esogena
era una logica,
ma noi l’abbiamo capito: non serve.
Il motivatore esogeno può stressarsi
a forza di dire “Fai”.
Ma se la fiaccola non si infiamma
e non c’è una motivazione endogena,
la società non evolve.
Quindi noi siamo su questa visione futura
in cui dovremo attivarci.
C'è una grande responsabilità
in tutto questo.
E torniamo all'individuo.
Siamo gocce dell'oceano.
Dobbiamo sciogliere il cinismo.
La goccia fa l'oceano.
La persona fa il futuro.
E non dobbiamo aspettare
una mano invisibile.
Non dobbiamo aspettare
una programmazione esogena.
Dobbiamo agire.
Dobbiamo agire verso un futuro
che costruiremo insieme.
Un futuro che ci abilita perché ci legherà
sul talento e le passioni.
E ai cinici che ci dicono
“Non ce la farete”, ricordiamo una cosa.
Potranno tagliare i fiori,
ma non fermeranno questa primavera.
Grazie.
(Applausi)